kotlin a statically typed multi-paradigm
language designed quite simply as a
better alternative to java like java it
compiles to bytecode that runs on the
java virtual machine but kotlin provides
a more concise syntax and language
features loved by modern developers like
type inference functional patterns null
safety and more it was announced in 2011
by jetbrains with the first stable
release coming in 2016. it's named after
kotlin island in russia and it just got
a mascot in october 2021 but it still
doesn't have a name yet one of its key
features is that it can interop with
existing java code which means
developers can gradually adopt it
without throwing all of their code in
the garbage in addition to jvm kotlin
can also compile to native code and
javascript opening the door to
multi-platform apps it's been most
influential in the android development
community and as of 2019 google named it
the preferred language for android
development over java one of its killer
features is co-routines which provides a
simplified way to write asynchronous
non-blocking code a common requirement
for mobile developers to get started
create a file ending in.kt most kotlin
developers use something like intellij
idea which is an ide brought to you by
the same company that invented the
language inside the file use the fun
keyword to define a main function this
is where your code will start executing
and that syntax is a lot more fun to
write than public static void main
string args declare a variable with the
var keyword assign a value and its type
will be inferred automatically or you
can add a colon after the variable name
with an explicit type a variable can't
be null unless you explicitly allow it
with a question mark on the type now use
printline to log the variable to the
standard output notice how semicolons
are optional which means that line
breaks are significant kotlin supports
familiar object-oriented patterns but
can do special functional things that
java cannot like modify the behavior of
a class without inheritance using
extension functions functions are first
class objects which means they can be
stored as variables passed as arguments
or used anonymously with lambdas kotlin
also reduces boilerplate with things
like data classes so you don't have to
write constructors getters and setters
and supports destructuring when
accessing the values on an object
allowing you to write concise efficient
code that you can then compile to a jar
file by pulling up the terminal and
running the kotlin compiler this has
been kotlin in 100 seconds hit the like
button and subscribe if you want to see
more short videos like this thanks for
watching and i will see you in the next
one